uh now we've been talking a bit about
the uh local elections already on the
program and now on thursday voters
across the uk will go to the polls
and because the votes postponed from
last year it's going to be the biggest
set of elections in the uk since 1973.
now arguably the biggest battle is in
scotland where voters will determine the
makeup of the next scottish parliament
parliament but throughout the campaign
we've interviewed all of the major party
leaders and today we're going to be
completing the set with the leader
of the scottish lib dems woody relly who
joins us now from
edinburgh thank you very much for being
with us so
the election's just a few days away
what's your pitch
liberal democrats want to put recovery
first not independence that means
cutting weights for mental health
treatment it means bounce back support
for children in schools it means
creating jobs for people
desperate for work and of course taking
action on the climate
in order to do that we need to bring the
country together we need to unite the
country because we'll need
the skills and talents of everyone to
get over these
massive challenges we shouldn't be
adding to the problems that we've
already got and the mountains we've all
got already got to climb
by adding independence into the mix
that will make it even more difficult to
get through this most deadly pandemic
where thousands of people
have died and thousands more have lost
their jobs so let's come together let's
put recovery first
and it's the liberal democrat seats in
this election that will make the
difference
between the parliament being focused on
recovery which liberal democrats want
and the parliament being focused on
independence which is what the snp want
so if you want to put recovery first
vote led them
at the same time though you i'm sure
will accept that's been a
pretty difficult few years for the
liberal democrats if you really want to
have the influence that you're talking
about
what would be a good night well we're
getting
more people coming to us from all sorts
of different backgrounds who are going
to vote for us this time
in particular people who voted snp and
for independence before
because they recognize that it just
seems the wrong time
to focus on another independence
referendum in the wake of one of the
most deadly pandemics
and they are voting for the liberals the
question was
what would be a good night for you well
what would be a good night for us well
i'd never put any limits on the number
of seats that we're going for i just
know we're going to grow with the number
of seats that we're going to
to gain in every part of scotland
because the beauty of this election
sophie
is that every single vote on the peach
ballot paper because remember we have
two votes in scotland
every single vote counts so if you want
to put recovery first then you need to
vote for the liberal democrats
in every corner of scotland and that
means that i know we're going to gain
more seats
put recovery first not the time for
independence that message
definitely coming across now you said
recently that you would vote
against another referendum on
independence at every
opportunity but if the snp
do win a majority how is it democratic
to resist that
well it's very democratic that i follow
what my voters tell me to do
i mean i'm against another independence
referendum because i think it will
distract the country at a time
they need to build recovery if people
vote for me on the basis that i'm clear
crystal clear
in an election campaign it would be
bizarre if i did the opposite
after the election but i don't accept
the premise of your question anyway
because all the polls are showing that
there's a decline in support
for independence and for the snp because
people know
now is not the moment to choose another
independence
referendum when we've got so many
challenges to overcome
i mean we've got a mountain of mental
health weights in this country sophie
over 1500
people wait over a year young people
wait over a year
to get mental health treatment that's 5
000 adults wait over a year
we've got one of the highest drug death
rates in europe three and a half times
what it is
in england we need to focus on these
challenges to try and get recovery
to improve ordinary people's lives we
won't get that with another independence
referendum and that's why i will not
support it
under any circumstances at any time you
say you're not support a
independent referendum under any
circumstances even if there is a
majority for
it you know the lib dem spent years
campaigning against the
brexit referendum result i mean is it
time to drop democrats from your name
i mean what we are saying is for the
next five years we need to put recovery
first that equally applies
to the issue of europe of course nobody
will be surprised that you know i'm a
very strong pro-european i was against
brexit i don't think it's good for the
country
but i recognize even i recognize that
the recovery has got to come first for
the next five years
that means putting aside the
independence issue and of course making
sure
that we smooth the relationship with
europe we make sure we can break down
the trade barriers
but now is the time to focus on the
recovery
not on the constitutional issues if it's
so important to focus on the recovery
rather than
independence why did you reject the
offer of the conservative party
to form a pro-union alliance well the
conservatives are part of the
problem in scotland and they brought us
brexit in the middle of our pandemic
we've seen all the the conservative
party is mired in sleaze
at westminster now what we need is a
progressive alternative in scotland
a party that's going to stand up to put
recovery first a moderate center-ground
center-left party
like the liberal democrats that will
focus on public services on improving
people's lives
not carrying on all the arguments about
independence
over and over again because that's what
the conservative party want
as much as the snp so if you want to put
all those divisions behind us
then you need to vote liberal democrat
in every part of scotland
i know it's coming across pretty clearly
your views about the conservative party
but at the same time if there was going
to be an independence referendum would
you
be prepared to hold your nose and focus
on a single cross-party campaign
i mean for goodness sake i mean we're
jumping several steps ahead here i don't
accept
that the snp or the nationalists will
get a majority because i think people
are going to
reject um the snp and their proposal for
another independence referendum
the idea that we're immediately into
another campaign just fills me with
dread so i'm not even thinking about
that stuff
i want to focus on the recovery because
that will be the way to improve
people's lives today okay willie rene
thank you very much for being on the
show much appreciated